Andrew could you summarize the sep
tember ratings in the NFL what they mean
and is it something that's temporary or
is there a trend morning dan I think
it's too soon I think we got to hold the
phone on any kind of trend and I know
every other sports league and TV program
would love to have this kind of ratings
problem but it is down I think we have
to look at a couple things number 1 2015
it seemed like every week we were seeing
some misses from the NFL about breaking
more records on their television ratings
so they're down from record pace and
then you sort of drill down the night
the night games are down the day games
really aren't night games couple reasons
maybe you know the marquee teams the
Broncos and Patriots without their
marquee players from last year brady and
manning maybe it has something to do a
lot to do in my opinion with the
election for those who haven't you know
been living under a rock for a year the
election is is polarizing which means
strong a lot of viewers to cable news
networks and those viewers would
otherwise be watching something else so
again I think it's short term it's
temporary but it's something to watch
also people brought up Colin Kaepernick
the protest factor with the NFL how much
do you think that is subtracted from the
ratings if it has it all yeah it's hard
to believe that it has I mean I I don't
know if you ascribe a negativity to that
because because you don't watch because
there's there's some protest angle you
think is hurting the game I I think it's
too soon for that as well I do think
this kapner Kaepernick thing what
everyone to call it is not going away
and they were going to continue to talk
about it but I don't I don't see that as
turning people away and the other thing
I heard dan is is the product now the
product you know we hear from these
coaches lament about lack of work in the
offseason and they're not developing the
skills that's a CBA issue obviously the
coaches weren't consulted that was
between the players and the owners and
everybody was okay with reducing the
offseason but that is something I just
don't know if viewer
generally I'm not talking about guys and
tunnel vision like us but generally
notice a difference in product based on
lack of offseason so again that's
another curious reason given that I see
but how big of a sample size do you need
before you say you know what maybe the
NFL's hit it hit its tipping point of
you can't over saturate the market
certainly beyond the election dan I just
think Donald Trump is like an accident
on the side of the road I'm not saying
that for political reasons I'm saying it
for ratings reasons he is that he is
ratings gold and I just don't think you
can make any assessments of evening
programming of the NFL going against
this election so I think if we start
looking at past November certainly when
you get into the key games in the key
part of the season then it's something
to be concerned about yeah but again
coming off record ratings and dealing
with this polarizing election if all
sports leagues were stocks which one
would you buy now a great question I'm
still buying blue chip here the NFL
provides this attractive programming of
perfectly packaged manicure games that
is hard to turn away from obviously it's
the blue chip in terms of rising stocks
I always look at the NBA because it's a
star driven labor star driven society I
mentioned Trump obviously this is
something where people are attracted to
the big names and the NBA has spiced up
so many teams with these tea with these
players that again are shiny objects you
can't turn away if the MMA were a stock
would you buy I think so because I think
what what this younger generation is
looking for is quick hit i meant pardon
the pun but quick hit action and it's
got it i mean i think i look at a
problem for the NFL going forward with
the time of games you know we're
packaging 11 and a half minutes 12
minutes of action in 2-3 and a half
hours and there's got to be an ability
to sustain younger
Dewar's that don't want to sit there now
fantasy and clicking channels and all
that keeps people engaged through all
these time stoppages but I think that's
a concern Andrew good to talk to you
this morning thanks for joining us
always a pleasure damn so andrew brandt
the mmqb kamo so the mothership the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience